>> IT'S FRIDAY.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
A VIRAL APP MAKES PRIVACY OF THE
PAST AND ANOTHER AMERICAN FLAG
UNDER ATTACK.
JOINING US WITH THE DETAILS,
RAYMOND ARROYO AND "NEW YORK
TIMES" BEST SELLING AUTHOR.
TELL US ABOUT THIS NEW VIRAL APP
THAT HAS EVERYONE HORRIFIED.
>> AND THE POSSIBLE DANGERS,
LAURA.
CELEBRITIES HAVE MADE IT
EXPLODE.
IT'S CALLED FACE APP.
IT'S A SENSATION.
IT TAKES A PICTURE, MAPS YOUR
FACE AND AGES YOU UP OR DOWN.
THE JONAS BROTHERS, MARIO LOPEZ
HAVE POSTED PICTURES OF THEIR
GERIATRICSELVES.
IT'S A BEST SELLER ON THE APPLE
STORE.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
USERS HAVE TO DOWNLOAD THE APP
AND UPLOAD PERSONAL PICTURES TO
IT.
ALL THAT DATA IS STORED ON
RUSSIAN SERVERS AND SHARED WITH
COMPANIES LIKE FACEBOOK AND
GOOGLE.
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER ASKED FOR
AN INVESTIGATION CITING PRIVACY
CONCERNS.
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE HAS WARNED CAMPAIGNS
TO DELETE THE APP.
THEY'RE WORRIED.
THERE'S CAUSE FOR CONCERN.
YOU AUTHORIZE WHEN YOU DOWNLOAD
THE APP EVERY PHOTO ON YOUR
DEVICE.
THIS APP HAS ACCESS TO IT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU AUTHORIZE IT.
IT'S AN IRREVOCABLE ROYALTY FREE
LICENSE.
I READ THE TERMS OF PRIVACY,
THIS IS LIKE A TWILIGHT ZONE
EPISODE.
THE WHOLE TOWN TAKES PART IN
THIS.
I DON'T LIKE IT AT ALL.
>> LET ME SAY THAT SOMEONE SENT
RAYMOND THE AGED FACE.
>> WE'RE NOT SHOWING THAT ONE.
>> WHERE IS YOUR AGED FACE?
IT WAS SO FUN ANY.
>> OH, NO.
NOT SHOWING THAT.
>> A FRIEND OF MINE UPLOADED
THIS PICTURE.
IT CAME BACK AS AN ARROYO
EMBRYO.
LOOK AT THAT.
I NEVER LOOKED LIKE THAT.
>> YOU LOOK THE SAME.
>> I LOOK GOOD.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A DISNEY
CHARACTER.
YOU LOOKED THE SAME.
RAYMOND DOES THE ONE THAT MAKES
HIM LOOK YOUNGER.
>> YOU THINK I'M CRAZY?
I SUBMITTED A PICTURE OF YOU,
LAWYE
LAURE
LAURA.
IT CAME BACK AGED UP.
>> I'LL TAKE THAT.
THAT'S A GREAT LADY.
>> JUST AGE NATURALLY.
WHY DO WE NEED A PREVIEW OF HOW
BAD WE LOOK?
IF YOU'RE LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET
OLD, EMBRACE IT.
>> ALL I CAN SAY IS PEOPLE HAVE
TOO MUCH TIME ON THEIR HANDS.
>> I AGREE.
>> WHEN YOU DOWNLOAD AN APP, YOU
HAVE TO PUT YOUR APPLE I.D. IN.
I CHANGE THAT ONCE A DAY.
I ALWAYS FORGET IT.
MAKING NEW PASS WORDS.
>> I HAVE TO SHARE THIS WITH
YOU.
WE COMMEMORATED THE 50th
ANNIVERSARY OF THE APOLLO 11
MOON LANDING.
ALDRIN AND ARMSTRONG WERE THE
FIRST ON THE MOON'S SURFACE.
THEY COMMEMORATED IT THIS WAY.
>> I WAS ABLE TO JOIN NEIL AND
MIKE ON THE SATURN 5 THAT DAY.
NOW I LOOK FORWARD TO AMERICA'S
LEADING ROLE IN A NEXT STEP
SPACE ALLIANCE.
>> BUZZ ALDRIN STILL KICKING.
UNBELIEVABLE.
DESPITE THE PICTURES AND THE
TESTIMONY, THERE'S STILL THOSE
THAT RENEWS TO BELIEVE THAT THE
UNITED STATES EVER WENT TO THE
MOON.
>> WE NEVER WENT TO THE MOON.
LET ME PROVE IT TO YOU WITH 13
REASONS WHY THE MOON LANDING WAS
FAKE.
>> WAS THE MOON LANDING FAKED?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE ANYONE HAS
EVER STEPPED ON THE MOON.
>> LAURA, THIS ALL REMINDED ME
OF A DAY BACK IN 2002 WHEN A
MILITANT MOON LANDING DENIER,
BART SIBRELL HOUNDED BUZZ ALDRIN
OUTSIDE A HOTEL.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
>> WHY DON'T YOU SWEAR ON THE
BIBLE THAT YOU WALKED ON THE
MOON?
YOU SAID YOU WALKED ON THE MOON
AND YOU DIDN'T.
CALLING THE KETTLE BLACK --
>> WILL YOU GET AWAY FROM ME?
>> YOU'RE A COWARD AND A LIAR --
>> ALDRIN POPPED HIM IN THE
MOUTH.
THE FIRST TIME AN ASTRONAUT SENT
A LAYMAN TO THE MOON WITHOUT
ROCKET PROPULSION.
A SMALL SMACK FOR HUMANITY.
>> "FLY ME TO THE MOON" BECAME
THE UNMENTIONED THEME OF THIS
ENTIRE LANDING.
IN HOUSTON IN 1969, SINATRA SANG
AT AN EVENT COMMEMORATING.
THAT DENIER, HE TRIED TO PRESS
CHARGES AGAINST BUZZ ALDRIN.
THE JUDGE THREW THEM OUT.
>> I INTERVIEWED THE FIRST
FEMALE CHIEF FLIGHT DIRECTOR ON
MY PODCAST.
SHE IS REALLY COOL.
SHE TOLD ME HER LIFE STORY HOW
SHE GOT IN NASA.
THE PEOPLE BEHIND NASA IN THE
ORIGINAL MOON LANDING AND ALL
THE ENGINEERING THAT WENT BEHIND
IT, THEY ARE THE -- THINK OF THE
ASTRONAUTS AND THEY'RE AMAZING.
THE UNSUNG HEROS, THE PEOPLE IN
THE EARLY 60s DOING HAND
CALCULATIONS.
PROPULSION CALCULATIONS.
>> WE HAVE TO GET TO CHRIS PRATT
THAT IS GETTING RAZZED WEARING
THIS T-SHIRT WITH A FLAG.
YAHOO PUBLISHED THE STORY.
SOME CHARGING THAT PRATT WAS
WEARING A WHITE SUPREMACIST DOG
WHISTLE, THIS IS THE DON'T TREAD
ON ME FLAG.
IN 1975, IT WAS A SYMBOL OF
LIBERTY AND FREEDOM.
THEY'RE CLAIMING THAT IT'S A
SYMBOL OF WHITE SUPREMACIST.
JUST BECAUSE SOME WHITE
SUPREMACIST USED THIS FLAG --
>> WHY CAN'T WE SAY THE ANTIFA
FACE MASKS REMIND US OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISM?
AND STORM TROOPERS AND EVIL
FORCES AND WE NEVER WANT TO SEE
THEM AGAIN?
THEY PLAY THIS GAME WITH
AMERICAN SYMBOLS.
>> THIS WILL KNOCK YOU OUT.
BETSY ROSS' FLAG IS OUT.
WE CAN NO LONGER FLY THE GADSDEN
FLAG.
THE SMITHSONIAN ASKED KATHY
GRIFFIN TO DONATE THIS DRESS
HOLDING UP THE DECAPITATED HEAD
OF THE PRESIDENT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO PRESERVE THIS
DRESS -- I DON'T KNOW WHERE I'M
GOING.
IF THAT GOES INTO THE
SMITHSONIAN, I'LL NEVER WALK IN
AGAIN.
>> DO THEY HAVE A BLUE DRESS
EXHIBIT WITH MONICA AND KATHY --
>> CALL MONICA LEWINSKY.
>> CAN THAT GO NEXT TO THE RED
RUBY SLIPPERS.
>> WONDERFUL.
ALL-AMERICAN DRESSES AND THE
LADIES THAT WORE THEM.